oder braucht er entweder stimmt decken
über das kann eigentlich nicht sein
verdammt hier wiederum das hin und hier
auch noch 119 tschuldigung dass ich
gerade wenig rede weil ich gerade
einfach ein wenig vertieft bin in die
tolle arbeit
wir müssen sand verbrennen damit wie
glas kriegen fällt mir auf ein apfel
pack da wir noch setzlinge so übrigens
hätten wir gehofft dass wir das tnt ja
gar nichts finden können was wir da
haben weil wir dafür ja feuerzeug oder
redstone brauchen und wir kriegen beides
nicht also wir brauchen ja dann gravel
für ein feuerzeug
ich habe mir noch kurz die ganze
setzlinge und pflanzt die dahin
eigentlich brauche ich gar kein holz
mehr aber ich sehe ganz einfach so aus
prinzip wieder hin damit trotzdem so ein
bisschen schöner aussieht welche die
ganze bäume ja auch eigentlich nur
hauptsächlich gepflanzt damit sie immer
ein bisschen schöner aussieht
nicht weil ich holz mangel hat er sich
hatte schon krass viel holz und da noch
einen takt gut was soll ich jetzt mal
holen
hier ist nichts gewachsen oder dann
müssen wir das wahrscheinlich wirklich
aufs tor machen und zwar wollte ich dann
noch stone verbrennen und
sand verbrennen und die kühlen lassen
kann ich auch wieder das dorf abbrennen
der staufer brambach die fallen aber
jetzt da unten rein ja toll super wie
kriege ich da dann die anleihen setzen
vielleicht schön verbrennen wie viele
bräuchten ungefähr 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
wenn luca das ist so eine einfache
aufgabe die jetzt auch im kopf rechnen
können das kratzen auch leute haben sich
darüber beschwert dass ich ja immer auch
so gras teilweise abgrasen weil ich da
einfach nicht treffe oder so auf einmal
wollen sie mich alle weil man wollte ja
alle
aber kommen nicht so an ihr könnt auch
beide noch kaum einer von euch beiden
kann doch wohl noch irgendwie egal
im fall wieder paar kleine küchen nicht
paar kleine küchen sondern egal ist dass
ich meine tochter also jetzt habe ich
gar nichts gemacht von dem was machen
wollte weil ich die komplette kohle auch
verbraten habe im wahrsten sinne des
wortes ich habe noch so viele setzlinge
die könnte ich auch ein bisschen
verraten aber offen
so holt das nicht immer gut
ich kann er dann wieder mal ein bisschen
sortieren susan boyle
doch dann brauche ich für das dach
wollte ich das nämlich jenen noch 26
müssten eigentlich reichen eigentlich
nicht
rotten flesh bisschen was zu machen
obwohl plans auch nicht dort nicht euch
beide brauche ich will zum essen doch
war am 9
den bogen über ziele spitzhacken habe
ich fällt mir gerade auf brauche ich
eigentlich nur die hier schaufel habe
ich auch brauche ich auch eigentlich gar
nicht ich rede gerade extrem leise fällt
mir auf dass sex brauche ich nicht den
sand bräunig cobblestone wollte ich
verbrennen stimmt fensters brauche ich
nicht mehr und schwert könnte ich noch
gebrauchen jetzt wieder kohle
soll das reicht
wenn ich ein verbrenner habe ich acht
das müsste eigentlich auch gehen und
sand wollte ich auch noch verbrennen
dafür könnte ich den sand ihr benutzten
den kinos ab beziehungsweise können in
der zwischenzeit doch eben noch ein
bisschen kopitz tonnen fallen dann habe
ich zwei öfen und da ich dann schon viel
hab habe ich sechs sieben acht neun bis
zu passen so und zwar nehme ich mir von
jetzt einfach 1 234 weg schon 38 perfekt
ich denke von oft ist es so dass ihr
einfach meine rechnungen die ich hier
mache nicht verstehe weil ich keinen
bock ob das alles so genau zu erklären
und es klappt aber das ist ganz gut so
jetzt wollen wir mal schauen ob das mit
dem pilz funktioniert also wenn ich das
mit dingens mache oder braucht er
bestimmte decken will das kann nicht
sein
verdammt ein verschwendet so den rest
setzt sich als auch noch hin habe ich
schon bisschen glas steiner hat es so im
moment so so so auch ich habe umstellt
angebracht schön so stone ist fertig ich
habe nämlich gerade gedacht dass der
stein eventuell noch den pilz kann der
stein wachsen weil ich eventuell kann
das ja sein man weiß es ja nicht so da
sind auf jeden fall stockfinster drin
halt die schnauze und wird euch gleich
alle ja ja das mache ich dann haben wir
jetzt mal ganz kurz die sachen rainer
kann ich ja eigentlich auch schon das
dach dann einfach mal eben aus sand
machen
ich wollte endlich so am ende hier so
alles in luft sprengen also natürlich
gebe ich euch das früher hat er da kann
ich das auch gelassen
wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch eine
menge glas danach soll das dach woltmann
machen stimmt da habe ich jetzt einfach
gedacht so ein bisschen sand drauf
kippen als wenn er wirklich so
verschollen wäre es wirklich dann als
wenn ihr so eine grube wer sage ich mal
als wenn ihr so sand drauf gefallen wäre
das wird wahrscheinlich nachher gar
keiner erkennen wenn er sich die welt
irgendwie runterlädt oder so als ich
letzte nacht zum download freigeben weil
es einfach dann so total bescheuert
aussieht
moment ich bin ganz sehr konzentriert
bei dieser konzentration aufreibenden
arbeit hier
moment so
verschwendet hier den kompletten sand
für
nein das reicht nicht alter oder doch
dass das kommt das passte da passt jetzt
so sieht doch gut aus bisschen
ausbaufähig aber naja dächer sind
allgemein nicht so meine stärke also ich
finde da kann man minecraft nicht machen
aber naja also für einen wüsten tempel
gsk asics ausstiegs dazu na ja gut dann
schauen wir hier nochmal bisschen wein
sondern haben auch glas her das glas
dann ist da noch darauf warten
da kann ich dann einfach gekommen dass
der ruf von alleine dann will ich sagen
gucken wir danach noch mal ganz kurz in
der monster falle und dann war es das
auch schon mit desert wasteland ja es
ist vorbei tut mir leid kann ja auch
nichts dafür dass das hier so schnell
vorübergeht
naja muss damit leben es kommen noch
weitere neue projekte und alte projekte
genau noch weiter und ich stelle das
jetzt gerade da als erste welt und dann
wird mal 4 5 6 7 8 brauchen wir noch
relevanter noch drin ich hab da noch
sechs oder oder wandert neuen da drin
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich mir noch ein
paar millionen hier
oder dass twitter seine zombie ich weiß
ich dass ich raus gepackt oder steht er
da so das kann man ganz einfach testen
und es steht also voll ist los haha
slams und wieder ab leider blieben
freunde hier ist wieder party hier
geht's los hier ist die party danach der
kontrakt sei natürlich nicht fehlen
jetzt richtig ab richtig viele monster
da kommt wieder eine ganze ladung
hierunter fakt das war jetzt natürlich
scheiße
auch die kacke ach du heilige nacht
heilige nacht und kacke ach du scheiße
ok ich würde sagen die monster falle ist
mal wieder mir die luft geflogen
kaputt gegangen naja gut also in monster
falle dem auf einfach nicht mehr rein
ich habe wieder übels viele sachen
gekriegt 11 knochen hat wieder 36 pfeile
das sehr krass und ich brauche etwas zu
essen
in essen das auto so wolter wieder meine
freunde
zack zack zack zack
also der bäume gewachsen ist auch ganz
gut 9 glas alkohol haben wir sogar so
ich packte aber noch ein bisschen was
rein passt genau glaube ich
das sieht auch blöd aus
zack zack zack bumm bumm bumm bumm 1
brauchen wir doch irgendwo für
verbrauchte wofür noch einzig glaublich
oder also hier ist alles voll hier auch
schön das war es also das ist jetzt der
tempel von xxxlutz einmal noch fackeln
in in einrichtung mache ich nicht weil
kann ich nicht also weil es gibt nicht
wirklich so sachen die man hinstellen
kann außer natürlich könnt ihr eine
treppe in stellen aber es geht ums
grundprinzip dass wir das ding hier
fertig gekriegt haben und das ist finde
ich schon cool so also der wüsten tempel
teil ist fertig sieht er aus wie so ein
haus aber egal
mal schauen ob die pilze gewachsen sind
wir haben auf jeden fall eine pilz
farben und ich weiß aber nicht genau wie
die funktioniert also so pilz von hamm
bockum war haben wir fast alle aufgaben
geschafft monster fall ein bisschen
kaputt gegangen aber na ja es passt
schon mal den ganzen items sich partie
mal hier rein damit ihr die auch nachher
auch alle habt wenn ihr die welt
irgendwie habt scheiße es passen die
sache nämlich rein salat im kreml den
setze ich irgendwohin und den kommission
auch dann habt ihr jetzt noch kunst soll
das kunst meine freunde gut ich würde
sagen das was mit der base line mit dem
kompletten projekt ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr diesem video und somit auch den
kompletten projekt einen daumen hoch
geben würde damit ich einfach sehe ob es
euch gefallen hat oder erhält einen
daumen runter wenn es total cup
gefahndet
das ist so meine welt nachher und dann
will ich sagen wenn ich nicht vergesse
gebe ich euch ein download-link in die
beschreibung könnt euch einfach
downloaden bisschen rum gucken da das
gehirn des geraten creeper und dann
sehen wir beim nächsten mal oder beim
nächsten projekt